l'engagement que je prends devant vous
c'est d'être à chaque instant dans le
respect de l'opposition de ne jamais
chercher les vaines querelles de ne
jamais de ne jamais convoqué les basses
polémiques et d'être dans un
comportement qui réhausse la politique
parce que les français qui louvoie sont
aussi des français qui nous jugent
l'engagement que je prends c'est de
chercher à nous montrer chaque jour à la
hauteur des ambitions de nos concitoyens
en s'adressant à là leur intelligence et
non comme vous le faites à leur instinct
à leur proposant des débats dignes et
des choix clairs
la campagne pour l'élection
présidentielle devra de proposer des
débats de fond
elle devra mettre en lumière des
différences de conception
celle qui nous oppose les uns aux autres
mais pour convaincre les français de la
justesse de nos choix
je veux consolider conforter et
amplifier l'action engagée par la
majorité depuis 2012 parce que cette
majorité s'est employé à redresser
l'économie et les comptes publics et
qu'elle a renforcé notre modèle social
parce qu'elle a préparé l'avenir de
notre pays à travers l'école à travers
les territoires à travers le numérique à
travers la transition énergétique à
cette tribune devant les représentants
de la nation
je songe à celui qui fut l'un des hommes
les plus admirables qui ait siégé dans
cet hémicycle
je pense à jean jaurès et elles exigent
message qu'il délivre à aux élèves du
lycée d'albi à jour de 1903 ce jour là
je reste il y avait 45 ans qui venait
d'être réélu député de carmaux s'est
adressé à la jeunesse de france et bars
de là le temps s'est adressé à nous et
voilà ce qui nous a dit le courage c'est
de se donner aux grandes causes sans
savoir quelles récompenses réservent à
notre effort l'univers profond nice il
réserve une récompense
mesdames et messieurs les députés
l'engagement ne se comptent pas en moi
ni le dévouement en semaine l'engagement
et le dévouement ne cherche pas la
récompense
il s'estime en réformes
poursuivi en actions menées en progrès
accomplis et dans les mois qui sont
devant nous je vous propose loup
consacrée aux grandes causes
et il n'en est pas de plus grande que de
servir notre pays
[Applaudissements]
bien